Trump doesn't even show up he goes and
does a town hall separately with Brett
Bear and Martha mcallum who would be in
the running for a vice president well I
can't tell you that really I mean I know
who it's going to be you give us a hand
I'll give you we'll do another show
sometime what about any of the people
who you've run against would you be open
to mending fences with I will I will
I've already started to like Christy
better christe chrisy for vice president
I I don't see it I don't see it that
would be an upset christe for vice
president you know and gentlemen I'd
like to announce just he's just having
fun at this point has Donald Trump
picked his VP I don't know he says he
has but has he I don't know or is he
just saying that because he knows that
if he says that that comment is going to
get more play in the media than anything
that was said at the official GOP
Primary debate